ce soir Pierre Palmade est toujours
hospitalisé au Kremlin-Bicêtre il y est
traité pour un accident vasculaire
cérébral qui l'a frappé samedi mais
désormais un garde est posté devant sa
chambre car il est en détention
provisoire à en croire les réseaux l'AVC
de Pierre Palmade c'est bidon alors
c'est pour ça qu'on détaille depuis tout
à l'heure autant est-ce qu'il se passe
vraiment mais oui si on en croit Twitter
c'est AVC est accusé soit d'être inventé
jamais eu lieu soit provoqué son avocate
n'aura pas réussi à lui éviter la prison
lors d'une audience à huis clos la
justice a rendu sa décision raison
invoquée le risque de récidive
l'humoriste a déjà été condamné
plusieurs fois pour usage et des
tensions stupéfiants un des lanceurs du
hashtag Palmade Gates c'est ancienne
star du petit écran que vous connaissez
Carl zero Camille feux web en laissant
entendre la semaine dernière chez
Hanouna que le sommet de l'État serait
mêlé à la faire certains participeraient
même aux orgies normalement sur ce qui
n'est qu'aujourd'hui
qu'un qu'une blessure involontaire le
client au pire il sort avec un contrôle
judiciaire et une obligation de soi
c'est le service normal
du complotisme Francis Lalanne qui lui
lance bienvenue au club Carl c'est une
légion d'honneur ces insultes et ses
attaques venant de la petite mafia
mondaine dépravée quand il se fait
interpeller par des jeunes sur la
question du climat où ils se font
ramasser sauvagement par le service
d'ordre ou alors il dit il y a pas de
débat possible il la France est en crise
elle est grave je me demande ce que fait
le président de la République après
Emmanuel Macron ce week-end c'est au
tour de la première ministre Elisabeth
borne d'arponter les allées du Salon de
l'Agriculture je n'ai pas trouvé de
colère chez nos compatriotes mais de
l'inquiétude a-t-il dit il est dans le
déni le président bon le président
d'abord c'est beaucoup caché c'est
beaucoup planqué alors c'est sûr que
lorsqu'on rencontre pas les français on
peut pas les entendre s'il a pas compris
que le pays était remonté comme une
pendule contre sa réforme des retraites
c'est qu'il a décidément rien compris
aux Français ce texte est devenu un
bazar indescriptible il y a plus un seul
Français qui nous écoute ce matin qui
comprend ce qui va l'attendre dans les
prochaines années avec ce texte de loi
qu'en plus dans sa sortie au salon de
l'agriculture il nous démontre qu'il ne
comprend rien non plus aux du monde
agricole le monde agricole subit un
véritable plan social ils vont aborder
ce texte en toute sérénité avec des
amendements de fond pour améliorer ce
texte il y aura pas d'obstruction de
votre part au Sénat il y aura un travail
de fond pas d'obstruction les LR ont
fait le choix n'ont pas de de se vendre
mais de s'offrir de se donner à Emmanuel
Macron or je pense que beaucoup
d'électeurs de LR notamment et bien ne
souhaitent pas cette réforme des
retraites donc là le Sénat LRZ s'apprête
à soutenir le gouvernement c'est un
moment de vérité
du Besiktas club d'Istanbul on fait part
de leur mécontentement à l'égard du
pouvoir ils ont jeté vous le voyez des
centaines de peluches sur la pelouse en
soutien aux enfants victimes du séisme
et ils ont appelé le gouvernement à la
démission un gouvernement critiqué pour
son manque de réaction c'est vrai qu'ils
sont en rupture de jet 27
les gens qui nous regardent dans les
entreprises il y a pas d'alcool que je
sache à cnews il y a pas une buvette
donc moi je m'interroge même sur le fond
d'avoir une buvette à l'Assemblée ils
ont que ça à faire tu les mets à l'Évian
un vivement critiqué depuis la
catastrophe le président turcardoen a
demandé aujourd'hui pardon pour la
lenteur des secours j'aime bon d'être
trouvé plus fort que lui en la personne
des scènes City Reader ses relecteurs
qui traquent les mots jugés choquant
pour notre époque on censuré plusieurs
passages des aventures de l'espion
britannique elles sont habituellement
réservées aux habitants des régions
polaires mais hier soir dans certaines
parties du pays comme le Nord il était
possible d'observer des aurores boréales
finissent le mot [__] et autres
références à caractère raciste sur les
Africains et afro-américain des années
50 et 60 désormais les lecteurs de
l'oeuvre de Yann Fleming liront le
barman au lieu du barman noir elle se
caractérise par ces traînés de couleurs
dans la nuit un rare spectacle que
beaucoup ont immortalisé en photo et
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux